hello you're watching games but daily
where we cover six news stories in 30
minutes or less or we get heavily
reprimanded by our bosses I'm Callie and
- Mike Ohio
what up we don't get reprimanded they're
very nice yeah because we're too good
you can can't say [ __ ] to us yeah we
always come in under 30 minutes actually
so far we have a really good track
record of coming in at every minute yeah
we specially do have to do to do that
today
so but in terms of the things that we
will run through in that 30 minutes we
got a we got a banger today cuz oh yeah
Sega Sega later laid down some laid down
some knowledge on us
on on a Friday night yo I was like
chilling here on a Friday night and then
I was like whoa why are you here on a
Friday night I'm always here on a night
on a weekday night sometimes on a
weekend night - well anyway we got a
couple things we got Shenmue a1 into you
collection Kingdom Hearts 3 mini games
Darksiders 3 publishers skipping III to
drink beer and more
I'm skipping I'm gonna skip out in the
rest of this day to drink beer I know
right turn up
alright well let's get to that first one
no story today so I can get to that turn
up real quick yeah all right Shenmue a
one-in-two collection announced but
they're not remasters which is this is
something that confused us initially
right right so Sega announced that it's
bringing a Shenmue a 1 & 2 collection to
ps4 Xbox one and PC later this year and
let's run through some of the revealed
features why don't you start yeah sure I
can run through all of them while you
pull up some hot b-roll uh some of the
revealed features are fully scaleable
screen resolution modern or classic
control schemes PC graphics options an
updated UI and both the original
Japanese and English voiceovers mm-hmm
so you can choose between those so the
games have some improvements but they
are specifically not HD remakes or
remasters which I'm so super confused by
what does that even mean literally
Michael wrote WTF does this even mean in
the show notes so you can say I maybe
they're like specific requirements that
will qualify something as an HD remake
I'm sure it has to do with the the
textures the like engine overhaul so
it's it's fine it's not actually super
confusing but it's a confusing sentence
for sure so there's just slight tweaks
but they're not don't expect like crazy
new shading and lighting and all that
that stuff well your mind yeah so
there's no release date or pricing
details on Shenmue 1 & 2 yet but they
will be available for retail and
digitally also on Steam for PC players
and yeah this I suppose this is supposed
to be in place to build up some some
hype for Shenmue 3 which is currently in
development so that's coming to ps4 and
PC but not Xbox one and is being
published worldwide by Deep Silver which
has been acquired by THQ Nordic which is
a cool hint for one of our later stories
today is all about second and THQ Nordic
yep let's leave it to launch sometime
this year that Shenmue III mmm I have my
doubts about it coming out this year
well the collection the one insu
collection is also coming out this year
supposedly so we'll see how that goes
okay maybe they'll surprise us this year
at e3 and drop like some hot gen move
three gameplay like man you know in a
world with Shenmue again I don't I don't
know how 1 & 2 is gonna hold up uh yeah
I know y'all look ya'll gonna be looking
for some sailors I'm gonna jump into
that and we wanted to mm-hmm
y'all get that if you played the first
game sure I'm gonna let you I just I
have to believe you cuz I haven't played
those anyway we didn't do a windy well
hard turn here as we usually do yeah
we'd love to do those alright so the
latest ps4 update asks to collect EU
players data so if you're in the
European Union wash you out so the
latest update basically appeared to be a
small one for stability and minor system
improvements but actually you users were
greeted with a message that Sony quote
may collect data about this ps4 and how
it is used
upon booting up so that's
great EU more like PU yeah data
collection hold on let's pull up some
yeah this is literally just a ps4
trailer because because we have nothing
else to show you show data collection
besides just showing Mark Zuckerberg
space was the last point you left off on
I left up on this one
so you're on here alright so it's not
clear if data was collected before but
this agreement is new there are two
types of data that may be collected
though data necessary to provide online
services and additional data that
includes navigation usage and settings
data and that's that's kind of the
creepy stuff but yeah the further there
there are further examples of the two
distinctions in terms of data so I think
we can now we can you take the first one
I'll take the second one great so
there's a separate about device data
screen and that gives examples so the
quote data necessary to provide online
services may include tracking what video
app you use in order to pay the
licensors for that content it needs to
track movements while playing an online
game so that players know where you are
and it also includes load times
error data and legal data and then oh
why don't you run us through what what
additional data here quote unquote
additional data when and how you use a
game's user interface which parts of the
game game level you visit which weapons
to use Oh which characters you interact
with so I really that's some next-level
[ __ ] right really don't like the which
weapons you use data point there like I
feel like that's you seem to like using
using an m4 and Call of Duty how about
this ad - you want to buy a real lab
form oh that's a no no yeah no don't be
serving me that them ads see the the
rule of thumb for the internet is if a
service is free you are the product so
that's just that's just a cool fact for
today my example was a little bit
extreme so I I'm sure that won't be
popping up in your your psn I'm just I'm
just I'm just messing with y'all all
right but the good news is you can
decline this agreement but you won't be
able to proceed without agreeing yeah so
you look at that you'll get that hot
update yeah I'm guessing that would
prevent you from using
your ps4 online yeah we would need the
update
sony says the data is used to provide
statistics improve products minimize
fraud and provide you with targeted ads
there's the last one like I said you are
you probably maybe you will get them you
get them hot ass your data is for sale
as we have learned that ads so this
message the message doesn't seem to
appear to us ps4 users but also I feel
like that's just one step away yeah
my homeboy Oscar de Road up the story so
he would be one to know because he is in
the UK yeah oh and then that might be
because of new data regulations from the
European Union which go into action in
May so maybe this it's a reaction to
that but if you're in the EU now you
know yeah so they don't your data is
being seized as we speak just thought
you should know you know you're all
probably asleep right now this one
alright yeah except tomorrow is always
online yeah all right let's do a little
scar scar yeah all right EJ's new chief
designer promises not to repeat
battlefront to loot box issues that's
nice this comes from the verge Patrick
soderlund was a head of EA worldwide
studios and is now EA's chief design
officer and he wants EA to learn from
the Star Wars Battlefront to loot box
disaster of last fall which we were all
hoping they would so we got some juicy
quotes from mr. most mr. so Dolan
himself so we're gonna read off some of
that to see how he really feels and I
want so really quick preferencing if
you're watching the video this b-roll is
from an old video we did going over
battlefronts loot boxes this is just to
illustrate what a mess that system was
this has changed this has changed since
then so I'll start with this this juicy
quote right here alright I'd be lying to
you if I said that what's happened to
with battlefront and what's happened
with everything surrounding loot boxes
and these things haven't had
effect on ei as a company and an effect
on us as management we can shy away from
it and pretend like it didn't happen or
we can act responsibly and realize that
we made some mistakes and try to rectify
those mistakes and learn from them
already and then he also talked about
how progression has changed since this
loot box controversy controversy he says
we got it wrong and as a result we had
to take a very quick and drastic act
wait we had to take very quick and
drastic actions to turn everything off
and we've since worked and redesigned
the progression system people seem to
appreciate what we've done players are
coming back and we're seeing stronger
engagement numbers people seem to think
that for the most part we got it right
it doesn't mean we will stop we'll
continue to improve the game will
continue to push on these things and
we'll have to be very cautious with what
this means for future products so
basically a lot of fancy executives
speak for yes we [ __ ] up but we
pivoted and hopefully we don't [ __ ] up
anymore
yeah I that's good to hear that's I
think what should happen and that's the
lesson learned from the battlefront to
controversy you know I think that when
kind of people people spoke up about the
the system that was in place for
battlefront 2 to begin with I think that
they very much heard your voices
obviously in a way that was very
powerful because they overhauled the
entire game so I think that speaking out
about this stuff made a difference
but and I think that it's gonna change
obviously like like Sodor only said that
it's gonna change the course of action
in the future for EA as it should but I
mean maybe this is the blast that we've
seen of this type of progression I
wouldn't say for sure but I think
they'll you know they they should have
something better in place for the future
games otherwise people be like you're
doing this again man I'm not having it
so I feel like if they did it again that
would be like you can't come back from
if they tried to pull something a second
time people would be like uh-huh like
they were already everybody was really
pissed off about battlefront to feel
like EA
like EA has to tread very carefully
because I feel like
patience is very thin yeah you know what
I mean and so as the chief design
officer I assume that he has more
control and more power and more say over
the these types of things so that the
fact that he's very aware of it as that
they probably they should be I think
that that will change the course of EA's
design design decisions when it comes to
microtransactions and loot boxes so
Michael transactions Michael transaction
making making his appearance early on in
the week you know hmm
Michael transactions that what a bastard
he is he's always here my boy he's not
my boy
and then up next from EA is anthem the
the one that everyone was like is it
like destiny is it destiny but worked
with more RPG and then also the next
battlefield game mm-hmm so here's here's
to hoping that EA doesn't not try and
pull a fast one on us
I mean yep alright and now it's the most
exciting story of the day is it yeah oh
yeah we got something that we're
probably really excited absurd this is
our headline story of the day Kingdom
Hearts 3 has Game & Watch style
minigames so a new trailer for Kingdom
Hearts 3 shows off what's called classic
Kingdom which is a game watch style
collection of minigames and the trailer
shows Sora Donald and Goofy playing that
little retro handheld console yeah and
jumping into some mini games it will
show you the trailer right yeah it looks
like they're playing in like in the
middle of Disneyland I think this look
this looks like Disneyland to me it it
straight up
looks like Downtown Disney yeah so
classic Kingdom has minigames that look
like Game & Watch games as you can see
from the b-roll you're looking at right
now mm-hmm and it's based on based on
classic Disney mini shorts not a shorts
that he's wearing but the short like
short animation Mickey's shorts yeah
Mickey shorts
not-not-not oh yeah not his physical
shorts but the yes yes short films
there's a Donkey Kong like game where do
you rescue mini which you just saw and
then a game where you dodge Jack and the
Beanstalk giant as you can see in the
top left there's like no the carnival
kid and there's some other ones Kingdom
Hearts theories co-directors says that
these mini games are
quote inspired by Disney cartoons and
1980s LCD games which i think is pretty
apparent just from looking at them yeah
so these minigames will be playable in
both Kingdom Hearts 3 and the mobile
game Kingdom Hearts Union across and
it's like as as per Kingdom Hearts
tradition it has like a weird like Greek
symbol instead of the actual word cross
oh no oh no hearts the naming
conventions in Kingdom Hearts confuse me
I've never played a Kingdom Hearts game
so I don't know a whole lot I just
really like Disneyland and that's about
my extent of you know play Kingdom
Hearts drop mixed to point a tree HD
remaster remix I'm just I'm not messing
with you right there's there's dream
Drop Distance hold on let's see to go to
point 8 365 over to the hole at e3 last
year Alec's new house and home girl here
they was trying to calculate like the
height of the parabola of Kingdom Hearts
yes so what we did was we took all the
Kingdom Hearts games and we we there's a
number of variables and Kingdom Hearts
games right I'll be really fast about
this ok there's a number of variables so
there's like the there's like a cross
and like there's a couple so we took the
derivative of all the Kingdom Hearts
game soon we did all this math I think
it's still on Alex's phone Oh quick
maths right there III was a fun time um
it was a fever dream anyway and it's so
close
III 2018 oh man really close oh that
that's gonna lead in somewhere next door
yeah oh we have a few more details
before we jump into that next three
Kingdom Hearts 3 is coming to ps4 and
Xbox one sometime in 2018 if we believe
the powers that be if you had to bet
money on Shenmue 3 or Kingdom Hearts 3
come in in 2018 which one would you bet
on probably I would bet on none of them
was a trick question
okay I'm keepin my damn money cuz I'd
maybe yeah that'd be great it would be
great if the book both those games come
2018 because they're makers and
publishers have set they're coming in
2018 so what we don't have a definitive
release date for King Hearts 3 yeah we
also have a 9 things we want from
Kingdom Hearts 3 feature up on
site if you want to get your your
thinking cap on get your your dream game
imagination flowin Kingdom Hearts Wow
2.8 dream daddy simulator wait that's my
ideal community I did one for Pokemon on
switch we do a couple like these like
kind of fantastical PI this guy what do
you want from this game so those are fun
if you want let us know what you want
from Kingdom Hearts I just I just want I
want that gummi ship minigame again that
that [ __ ] was tight I just really want
to go to Disneyland I haven't been to
Disneyland in years and I used to go
once a month because I lived 45 minutes
from Disneyland and I had a pass and I
would go all the time and I haven't been
in years and I don't feel complete so
that's all I have to say about that um
anyway speaking of III like we did a
couple minutes ago yes someone will not
know a group will now be at e3 known as
THQ Nordic yeah so Darksiders three
publisher THQ nordic won't be at e3 this
year and they literally said that they'd
rather be watching the World Cup and
drinking beer which you know what I
support that I support them a lot so THQ
Nordic released a press release and it
said and well actually you know what I'm
gonna pull up some Darksiders 3 okay
sure footage so we can watch this but it
says in their press release it is with
great regret that we at THQ Nordic must
report that we will be unable to miss a
single moment of this great sporting
event referring to the World Cup World
Cup
therefore we will be forced to stay in
our lovely Viennese beer gardens blowing
the froth off a couple watching football
and one or two cool press conferences on
Twitch looking at you devolver instead
of rocking it ourselves
damn straight up and they are in Austria
so it is a bit of a trek to get your
free they would have to go all in on
their trip so I guess I don't blame them
for one I'm gonna kick back and so yeah
THQ Nordic is based in base in Austria
but they are also a Swedish the company
is of Swedish descent and they they
addressed this too and I love this quote
so much we have to admit we are going to
miss our 9:00 a.m. pint of beer in the
ye old King's Head pub in Santa Monica
where they show all the matches live but
with the World Cup being held in Russia
it would mean a 7 a.m. beer
that's too early even for Austrians let
alone the Swedes oh man no no I I
disagree with that dude I don't think I
could have a beer at 7:00 a.m. I would
like vom really be to it sure I've been
on very early flights mimosa at 7:00
a.m. oh yeah guess what's up yeah beer
at 7:00 a.m. I that's tube ready
that's too much credit you'd be so full
then you fall asleep like it's like it's
like drinking your toast I literally I
went to a beer garden they're talking
about beer grants I'm gonna be regarding
over the weekend and I ended up and you
drank at 7:00 a.m. or 9 8 no I started
drinking like 1:30 and that was the only
no that wasn't too early but I went to
bed before midnight because so tired
yeah it's never too early
yeah it's never over never ogre yeah
turn out there now I've been on flights
or I've been on flights I Eve you've
been on flights before well I
I've waited at airports like for very
early flight it's like 6:00 a.m. flight
snow and I like the places are open like
everywhere in the airport it's kind of
open so I'm just like hey I'm gonna get
an IPA just get Rick yeah that's what I
did and like I mean I'm a grown-ass man
so I didn't get rid huh
but I am like anyway there's good news
if you're a fan of Darksiders and you
were hoping to see jar size 3 soon THQ
nordic did say it resent all of its
upcoming games including Darksiders 3
bio mutant fade to silence rec fest and
some unannounced games at Gamescom in
germany I can't talk today and PAX West
in August which is a similarly long trip
but not during the World Cup so I was
doing that's how they're going to pack
well THQ Nordic has been kind of on a
trip themselves in terms of the status
of the company THQ itself has gone
through some some [ __ ] I suppose but THQ
Nordic was acquired by all Koch media's
assets back now they acquired it I'm
sorry they acquired all Koch media's
assets back in February which included
the developers of the Metro series are
yeah which yeah Metro series and Saints
Row volition
so they had got volition and deep silver
but Deep Silver will be at e3 so we will
probably see some more Metro Exodus so
if you are holding out for Metro Exodus
like I am and yes a lot of us out here
rhetoric at that trailer had the 28 days
later music did it yet did the last last
years either yeah so pumps
yeah 28 28 days later is dope because as
a Killian Murphy in it alright yeah
killing Murphy oh I love that dude me
too but yeah so the interesting thing
about that Cook media acquisition was
that volition the developer of Saints
Row used to be under teach to you before
THQ went under yes a THQ Nordic still
exist
so now volition is under the THQ
umbrella again which I think it's cool
it's these company acquisitions can make
your head spin yeah money stuff is hard
yeah business business business but
we're gonna take a break from business
here we're gonna talk about you know
we're getting down to business
serious business right here you know
speaking of companies acquiring each
other or the relationship between
different companies Sega I can't talk
today so man Sega owns Atlas or the
parent the parent company of Atlas is
Sega and if you know Atlas is the
developer of persona mmm-hmm so Sega put
out a poll asking fans what crossover
what what crossovers would they want in
the persona dancing games and you know
what we got oh yeah Kooza Yaga's our
costumes are coming to persona 5 dancing
star night y'all and also sonic I guess
yeah I guess yeah sonic sonic school I
guess so this is from persona central
uh-huh okay I'll let you take this cuz
you were clearly so pumped ok so meet me
Ben
djenka and John Luke was like man I wish
there was like some Yakuza persona
crossover because you know Sega kind of
has their hands in all these series and
they're like two of my favorite game
series in fact three of you just did a
why you should play Yakuza
Oh video so you should watch that after
this yeah but the story of the day is
that so they put out a pause Sega put
out a poll asking them what they what
fans would want and 46 percent said that
they would want Yakuza
silver into persona so what we got here
is presenta five dancing on the dancing
star night will have the opposite theme
costumes as DLC so it appears that
images here yeah that's the persona 3
one let's go uh can you enlarge yeah
enlarge that one ok so let me run let me
run through this is so ridiculous right
here but it makes me so happy so the
main protagonist who is rent Amamiya now
that he's an anime yes so you dressed up
as cosmic you you on is dressed up as
construction Mishima she's one of the
hard hat hilarious and she's on the
snakeskin jacket so good with the eye
patch I was like ok she could pull it
off yeah and of course Ryu G is dressed
up as Ryu G Goethe
who is the main antagonist of Yakuza 2
naturally uh-huh
and then Yusuke is dressed up as Akiyama
and makoto is dressed up as a Jamaa who
are both main characters in yoga for
alongside kiri and Haru is dressed up as
Haruka who is more or less curious a
step child
no not sceptile is a more or less his
adopted daughter let's just say that so
and then lastly we have Morgana dressed
up as Sonic that's that's that's dope
like this is I I'm so happy it's cool I
guess no no no shade to you Sonic fans
out there you gotta get a little Sun
song
Oh what about futaba's oh for toddlers
dressed up as the florist it was the
information broker and the Yakuza series
he's a cool dude
I this is dope I like this is so cool oh
man I saw that in the morning uh was it
Ben and gianluca were tweeting it
they were tweeting it at me as well and
I woke up I was like what is actually we
have gameplay oh yes okay let me pull up
this gameplay really fast we don't even
need to pause we don't even let's just
go okay so also persona 3 dancing Moon
Knight will have will have the Virtua
Fighter costumes so if you're into
Virtua Fighter you can get those DLC
costumes for persona 3 the dancing game
for that but there's no price or release
they set to the for the DLC and
so uh so most of this video is Morgana
dancing because this is one of Morgana
songs and he's got his sonic costume on
so it won't be too like later in the
song you got to see I think on is gonna
show up here just abismo jima oh my god
this is how I look when I dance I'm not
gonna lie I am obsessed with this I'm
obsessed
Morgan is like stumpy yes like I'd it's
kind of like like this I do the same
thing
oh is it cuz because you're Wyatt so no
if it's because I'm white but I mean
maybe there's a correlation someone my
folk out there can dance so I know Shay
- yah there you go there's on dresses
actually maybe I look more like that
because I have a full-length legs is
that buffering or is that just me I
think that's just the the stream quality
that came out of well you get the idea
so this is this was from Sega Sega Fest
2018 that happened on Friday where they
revealed a bunch of stuff oh man that
was that was the most important part so
there's a couple more things that came
out of that so there they showed the the
full the full intro themes and intro
movies for both persona 5 and persona 3
dancing games were revealed and Lin
Inazuma who is the singer for persona 5
soundtrack she's actually professionally
known as just Lin she performed the full
versions of both the the persona 5 anime
theme song and the persona 5 dancing
theme song so if you can dig that out of
the Internet you can watch that it's
pretty dope whilst watching it this
morning yeah so a lot of cool stuff came
out of Sega fest 2018 did you talk about
the release dates oh yes
no I didn't but yes I will so persona 5
dancing star knight and persona 3
dancing Moon Knight will release in
Japan on May 24th but there is no word
on a North American release date and I'm
waiting for that announcement so it
let's be real I'm pretty sure that I'm
not worried about that coming to the
West
yeah there's I would say about three to
three and six months I think has been
the general
a window for localization or together
for us to get the final localized
version here out in the West but I was
also considering what do you call it
importing these Japanese I guess you
don't really need to read any Japanese
to play a dancing game yeah some of them
well some of the menu stuff is also in
English I think okay yeah so I can
navigate the menu my favorite thing was
I was asking Ben genka how much Japanese
he can read and he was like well I know
how to say pause loading like Oh in port
games yep
the important things need oh yes yeah
and then lastly on the persona know
persona 5 the animation is currently
airing you can watch it on crunchyroll
and hulu in north america i believe it's
also on crunchyroll in a bunch of
different regions i have an article up
on gamespot on how to watch it where you
can watch it when it's airing all that
stuff the the lowdown of what you need
to know so you can find that on case but
just look how to watch percent of 5
anime and to find it but crunchyroll and
I like that you wrote brunchy roll
Brunton roll which is I have friends who
work at crunchyroll and I really want
them to have crunchy roll brunches
called brunchy roll maybe cool anyway
let's get it so that's your anime note
we can talk about episode 2 another time
because we are running out of time today
yeah we want to thank we want to thank
our crew we got Matt Padgett and Tony
Wilson who get us all set up and get our
nuts going we got Emily Conti who made
our whole studio look a lot nicer and
made us look less sweaty cuz we looked
real sweaty when the lights weren't as
nice and shouts out to Kuya Eric Tay
mm-hmm that's my boy and shout-out to
all y'all for joining us and who are
going to watch this or who have watches
because this is the end of the episode
thank you all for joining us we love
having you here and chill with us talk
about all the hot news in the world of
video games mm-hmm we will see you
tomorrow
well you won't see me tomorrow because
I'm actually off on a secret mission you
may or may not see me that that is still
to be determined but there will still
will be an episode tomorrow so stick
around for that get your news here yeah
if you're tired of it one of us
hopefully you'll see a new face but you
know you're always gonna get me and
Callie here every week so stick around
for that anyway thank you for watching
and have a wonderful day bye bye bye
you